inside let's go
the evil within doesn't rely on cheap
jump scares it's driven by a slow
sustained and pervasive sense of dread
that sets your mind racing at every
crunch of glass beneath your feet and
every distant groan from an unseen enemy
much of this tension is thanks to the
game striking use of atmosphere but it's
also a testament to an action heavy
combat system whose scant ammunition an
immediate threat of death is just as
demanding as it is satisfying were it
not for the occasional stumble into
moments of immense frustration and an
aimless sputtering story the evil within
could have been something truly great
what's left though is an uneven but
still enjoyable ode to the glory days of
survival horror
at the center of it all is Sebastian
Castellanos a detective called in to
investigate a vicious collection of
murders at a local mental hospital the
brief preamble leading up to this
investigation is all the calm that the
evil within can muster because from then
on Castellanos is sent tumbling through
a twisted and only occasionally coherent
story involving supernatural apparitions
gruesome monsters and a seemingly
infinite series of nightmarish backdrops
it's not a good story
nor is it self-aware lacking any trace
of that cheeky almost a Jill sandwich
charm of early survival horror games it
is genuinely earnestly bad
Castellanos is a wooden and thoroughly
uninteresting protagonist a gruff cop
with a dark past who drinks his problems
away
then there's the overarching plot so
meandering and slipshod with its
constant jumps in and out of Castellanos
is tormented visions that all this
narrative trickery becomes routine even
numbing in a way and so the world lacks
context but it doesn't lack impact the
evil within is a horror experience built
on such an outstanding foundation the
chilling use of light and shadow the
menacing audio flourishes that merely
traversing through its environments is
enough to make your heart skip a few
beats whether it has you exploring a
derelict hospital ward the catacombs
beneath an old cathedral or even that
most weathered of survival horror
settings the creepy mansion the evil
within transports you through a diverse
assortment of places with one theme
tying them all together an absolutely
terrifying sense of atmosphere there's
more to contend with an eerie sights and
sounds of course the evil within is full
of grotesque creatures who relish every
opportunity to rend you limb from limb
there are the vaguely human monsters
that populate early chapters wielding
hatchets and hurling sticks of dynamite
like supercharged zombies but as the
game wears on you're pitted against
increasingly nasty and more challenging
foes but no matter where you are in the
game's lengthy story death is never far
around the corner the evil within is a
brutal experience where the
slightest lapse in concentration can
turn you into a pool of viscera on the
ground ma as a result caution and
patience are your greatest allies in
this fight for survival
every handgun round feels precious every
healing syringe feels like it could be
your last but for a stingy as the game
is with its resources it's also rich in
choices do you shoot an enemy in the leg
and burn them Wally's down or risk going
for the head shot do you throw a bottle
to lorem toward a booby trap or Salvage
to the trap for parts to craft a new
crossbow bolt you're always making these
tense moment to moment decisions that
challenge your creativity and
resourcefulness but when your craftiness
pays off and you manage to scrape
through an encounter with your body
intact the payoff is immense and beyond
that the combat just feels good the
weapons are impactful headshots are
suitably gruesome it all just works the
evil within does a remarkable job of
pushing you to your limit but there are
moments when it crosses that line and
the experience suffers for it the
autosave system is a finicky little
thing that behaves by its own strange
logic firing off a bunch of saves at
some points and holding them back for
long stretches at others then there are
the boss battles most are enjoyable
encounters forcing you to take the same
wits and creativity you've been refining
in basic combat dial them up to a whole
new level
but others require these very specific
very obtuse secondary goals hidden
somewhere in the environment it's these
fights that you need to plow through
over and over until you figure out the
right process a chore made even more
tedious by the game's Glacial load times
and habit of repeating the same boss
introduction cinematic
but those are a few clumsy missteps in
an otherwise captivating game because
for as much as the evil within does
stumble it always seems to recover what
it does at its core it does smell well
but all those issues floating on
periphery just eventually fade away to
reveal a satisfying if slightly
blemished return to classic survival
horror